forty-eight is considered a young age
isn't it for prostate cancer you got
tested early it's a very controversial
subject the PSA test right yes a test is
the only early screener for prostate
cancer and right now the United States
Preventive Services Task Force does not
recommend to take the test I think
American Cancer Society says you should
discuss it at 50 if I hadn't gotten the
test at my doctor started giving it to
me about 46 right I would not have known
and right now I still wouldn't have
known so do you think everyone should
get that PSA test in their 40s I do
personally right in terms of the
recommendation I think everybody should
discuss it with their doctor and should
have the opportunity to discuss it with
their doctor and that's why I think the
US Preventive Services Task Force should
change their guideline and recommend
that you agree with that doc I do yeah
the first PSA test after the surgery
came in good yeah and then that was like
but then there's another PSA test what
like about a month after mm-hmm isn't
that kind of like your first like real
murder how accurate is it super super
super yeah so I saved my little Tweety
Bird band-aid that you know for my blood
test yeah and I you know and I put it in
a little book just to remember how great
I felt when I got that first you know
three-month clear and now you felt
comfortable enough two years later to
say hey I went through this and things
are normal I wanted to talk about it
because of the test because I feel like
the test saved my life well I'm glad
you're alive Thank You Man that [ __ ] is
nothing to be screwed with and guys get
that PSA test I'm actually my doctor
meet me here in 10 minutes